ja wir wollen noch etwas mehr über diese
tests sprechen über die wir ja gerade
schon etwas gehört haben zwar mit
professor klaus-dieter zastrow einem
hygieneexperten guten morgen herr
professor zastrow ja diese schnelltests
die dort jeder gast bekommen haben soll
wie aussagekräftig sind sie tatsächlich
ist dies ja man ist für einige tage
inkubationszeit ist nicht ganz klar
also ist es wirklich sicher wenn jeder
dort ein negativ test hat und dann zur
party geht dass ich keine anstecken kann
na ja sicher ist natürlich gar nicht in
der welt aber was ich sehr interessant
finde und mein vorredner hat das ja eben
auch schon betont und darauf sollten uns
konzentrieren
die rechtliche würdigung ist ja auch
schon gemacht worden oder wird auch noch
vielleicht genau gemacht aber natürlich
sind diese schnelltests aussagekräftig
es wird geredet von 80 97 prozent also
da ist eine variable da drin und wenn
jetzt nur leute hinein kommen dürften zu
der party die eine negative stellte
hatten also wo ein nachweis nicht
gelungen ist dann ja dann wird das
wahrscheinlich auch genauso mit seinen
97 prozent zu treffen und ich finde es
eben auch eine sehr interessante varianz
die jetzt hier eingeführt worden ist und
man sollte sich überlegen ob man das
nicht generell macht man gute haben wir
sonst ein schnelltest natürlich auch für
andere dinge oder ist für andere dinge
auch gemacht worden aber an der stelle
ist es eben auch sinnvoll diesen
einzusetzen und dann möglich um damit
möglicherweise sehr viel mehr öffnen
dieses leben aufrecht zu halten wenn
jemand negativ ist ich habe das auch
schon oft genug betont wir laufen hier
nicht durch eine krone wolke
den ganzen tag wenn kein
ansteckungsfähigkeit da ist dann ist
natürlich die frage wozu machen wir das
noch unser da müssen wir jetzt die
richtige korrelation herkriegen und hier
hat sich einer was getraut
inwiefern das jetzt rechtlich zu
würdigen ist muss man noch sehen aber
entscheidend und wir sind auch gespannt
ob wir dann in ein paar tagen etwas
erleben dass das von dort aus
kontaktpersonen oder auch erkrankte
gemeldet werden aber generell finde ich
auch den weg stellt es zu machen und
nach dem ergebnis des schnelltests zu
entscheiden darf der rein oder nicht das
finde ich eigentlich eine sehr gute idee
jetzt sagen sie es müsse jetzt ein paar
tage abwarten um zu sehen was für
auswirkungen das tatsächlich hatte und
am montag wird auch wieder erneut über
den lockdown gesprochen in dem wir uns
ja gerade alle befinden momentan die
stimmen aus der politik zeigen das wird
erstmal keine lockerungen geben wir
müssen uns vielleicht sogar noch auf
eine verlängerung einstellen wenn sie
und andere jetzt aber sagen solche
schnelltests sollten dafür sorgen dass
wir eigentlich sogar wieder zurück in
clubs können da muss man ja jetzt die
maßnahmen noch mehr infrage stellen als
das einige sowieso schon tun oder
na ja wir haben ja auch schon davon
gesprochen dass wir die risikogruppen
besser abschotten besser heißt der nur
konsequenter zum beispiel eben auch da
schnelltest einführen den sonst brauchen
wir keinen schnelltest wenn wir sie so
die ich nutzen und und das gilt für die
risikogruppen genauso wie eben für
solche man kann ja auch sagen
kontrollierten veranstaltungen also das
ist ja insofern keine veranstaltung
gewesen zu der jeder rein und auskommen
konnte das waren offenbar nur geladene
gäste die da gibt es bestimmt auch eine
gästeliste die kann man auch
nachverfolgen und wenn die dann getestet
worden sind dann spricht gar nichts
dagegen ich sag mal wenn sich 200 corona
freie nicht ansteckungswege menschen
dort eine party feiern dass das ist das
entscheidende
ja wir müssen ja nicht alle
sachen dicht machen wir überhaupt keine
coronaviren da sie ja also das wird doch
unglaubwürdig und und man fragt sich
natürlich was soll das also wir haben
die möglichkeit jetzt zu testen wir
sehen ist es negativ dann fröhliches
feiern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren